[Music]
so you start dna you introduce yourself
and what you do please
and the slides i'm asking the slides to
be uh put on i think we have all slides
i hope okay yes
okay so good morning everyone so my name
is janet ake i'm a data scientist
working at contemporary a french
consulting company in paris specialized
in data science and artificial
intelligence
and so today i'm here to present you
mapi an open source python package
for estimating uncertainties associated
with the prediction of machine learning
models so as you know
estimating uncertainties from
ml models is of crucial importance
so it can
allow data scientists and engineers to
assess the limits of models in
productions in industry and you can also
of valuable importance for decision
makers in business units for instance
so but to our knowledge we didn't find
any robust uh package at least in python
allowing you to easily estimate
uncertainties for machine learning
models
uh in regulation and classification so
we decided to develop this part this
package on a two-fold objective
as the name implies
the first objective is to have a modal
agnostic
estimator that can be plugged to any
machine
machine learning model for regulation
and classification settings the only
constraint is to have a circuit learn
compatible
model
and the second
objective is to implement
a
of state-of-the-art uncertainty
qualification algorithm
that gives you mathematical mathematical
guarantees on the marginal coverage
either for regression or classification
so we developed this package with
standard open source
specification basically it's published
on github documented on rent docs
we
also packaged it on pipey and gronda and
it's now part of circuit.contrib
ecosystem
so it's fully compatible with
scikit-learn and
if you want to know more so please feel
free to stop by to see our poster
thank you
i was told that you have to use the
standing microphone there
hello everyone okay
my name is amku salim i'm a phd student
at stellantis i will present a joint
work with nicola brunell from
consummatory
so i'm going to talk about
exploration tools
local explanation methods
today there are against many
explanation methods that try to explain
the local behavior of machine learning
system one of the most popular are
future attribution bays for example with
sharp or lime
also this meter gives some insight about
the local behavior of the model they
have many issues which make them less
reliable for example they are very
sensitive to persuasion they are poor to
detect local behavior of machine
learning system
and their additive natural or linearity
assumption make them
prevent them to explain interaction and
more complex effects
on the other side there exists other
methods that are less popular but more
reliable which are rule-based
explanation and solution explanation in
one word reflection the idea of
sufficient explanation is to find the
minimal subset of variables that
maintain your prediction with a high
probability however these methods are
not currently available in a realistic
case for example they are only
available in classification problem of
binary features and we have strong
knowledge about the distribution of the
features for that our work uh the main
goal of our work is to provide a method
that
that overcome this limitation for that
we extend the
the idea of shifting explanation in
regulation seating for that we find a
way to compute this explanation for any
distribution and we prove the
consistency of the algorithm
and we also based on this destination
provide a rule-based estimation for
regression and classification problems
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
my name is uh stefan zuvlak i'm ceo and
founder of renumix we're a small startup
out of classroom in germany and i'm
really enjoying being here today
maybe you can put on the slide one more
because
yeah perfect um and we built uh ml power
tools for mechanical engineers and
through our projects we learned that the
main point the main success factor for
these tools is the data centric
collaboration between the domain experts
and the data scientists and i believe
that this is also a very good bridge
to have enhanced on approach to build
trustful ai what do i mean by this if
somebody tells you the data scientist
tells you oh well i have an accuracy of
95 percent on f1 score of 0.9
would you trust the system would you use
the system would it tell you anything
for me it basically tells you nothing
and at least three components are
missing in that first of all you
typically need more information from
your model we heard it in the talks
before you need information about the
uncertainty
about the embeddings about the feature
importances
and then you need not only the
quantitative results but we feel on we
see it every day that you also need the
qualitative results you have to look at
the data points in groups and
individually so
how
do certain
where are actually my errors occurring
what does these errors have in common
and you have to do this in close
collaboration between the domain experts
especially in engineering and
manufacturing
and the data scientists
and to enable this workflow we've
developed a template we call it the data
curation
canvas it's basically a set of best
practices and we develop software that
help to build these data curation cycle
and to help build data curation
flywheels and we feel it's a very
interesting area and if you've already
built perhaps some
data analytics visual analytics tools or
data curation tools i would really love
to learn from your experience and please
meet me at the posters thank you two
minutes exactly
[Applause]
so now we have number five maxim
okay
okay so
hi i am maxim savari lebron i am a phd
student at the university of lille and
the ceo list
and today i'm going to talk about
fostering trust in software assistance
for software engineering so this morning
we were mentioning
human aspects of ai systems
and imperfect systems so let me start
with a short story
a few weeks ago we were interviewing 16
software modeling experts who model
critical systems and we were introducing
them with software assistance to help
them modeling in fact this specific
software system was
an artificial intelligence knowledge
based system which provides with them
with recommendations about modeling
so we're asking a lot of questions and
especially the following can the system
provide bad recommendation wrong
recommendations
and surprisingly they said yes yes the
system should provide bad
recommendations so this was kind of
funny and the justification was even
better
they said we want bad recommendations
because a bad recommendation is bad from
one perspective one point of view but
from another point of view maybe it's a
good recommendation
so in fact maybe
me
the muddler is wrong and the system is
right maybe i just should change my
approach and maybe the system is right
and i am wrong
so
this says that when it comes to
assisting people with our
intelligence systems
high accuracy is not the key high
performance is not the key but the
system should enable the trust
relationship to grow between the user
and the system
and this is um what we present in this
posture we present an approach
which define what is a software
assistance so it is a system based on a
knowledge base an algorithm and one of
several user interfaces and we provide
preliminary guidelines and directions on
how to
create this relationship based on seven
criteria for uh information throughout
worthiness based on the scientific
literature so the rest the rest in front
of the poster yeah
thank you
[Applause]
hello everyone i'm laurence guillen i'm
working at a naval group
on predictive maintenance
so
we have time series data
from raw
it's raw data from capitals
it can be a capitals of a temperature of
oppression etc
and
we have a massive amount of
data
but most of data is not complete
and
the sensors
have a bad
sometimes have bad quality and quality
is not monitored
for the capture
and it's a bar elaborates label it so
sometimes there is label but we don't
know if they are true or not
so we have to do anomaly detection on it
and we did
testing uh different algorithms
for anomaly detection of this kind of
data
and
here are
the results of
all the algorithms are on the poster
[Applause]
number seven mark
hello everyone
so i'm mark naban i'm a data scientist
from early kids and together with luka
moschini from centex gpre we're going to
present
a predictive uncertainty quantification
for time series in the scope of
confines.ai project number three
and its application on the early kid use
case which is the demand forecasting
so to be quick
the context of the use case it's uh we
want to predict the future trends of
customer customer demands as precisely
as possible
uh we have a data set comprised of
historical consumption geographical
distribution as well as sensitive uh
customers information and seasonality
data
we have a first solution uh an exhibit
that can predict value prediction as
well as a gradient boosting regressor
which can predict intervals prediction
but our objective is
to obtain prediction intervals that can
have a theoretical guarantee and as well
as be the most precise as possible so we
begin by inspecting our first method
first category of method which is the
quantile regression for prediction
intervals so if for example to what is
the prediction intervals we have um the
probability of to have a prediction
intervals we defined as one minus alpha
when alpha is the miscoverage error for
example if you want 90 coverage error
of coverage we define alpha as 10
percent which is the error and the
quantity regression can estimate some
quantile estimations to have an upper
bound and a lower bound together where
we can establish 10 error and maximum in
both cases
so now luca will continue to
more talk about the conformalization in
20 seconds yes definitely
so um
what we are applying is a conformal
prediction and it's a very simple method
to add a
a um
to wrap around this classif this
regressor classifier with a to provide a
formal guarantees that are model
agnostic distribution free and
non-asymptotic so if you do mean based
regression the usual one you have a
point estimate and you have you can add
error margins that are
going to give you a prediction interval
that on the long term on the predictions
on the test predictions will guarantee
that you will have the
the true the true y point
in the in the interval and we can do
this with quantum regression so we have
lower quantile up quantile we can either
make it larger or shorter and then this
prediction will be guaranteed on the
long term to contain the true data so in
the poster you can see uh the first
application so we have taken a uh
conformalized quantile regression which
is great come see the poster
oh thank you very much
[Applause]
number eight
yeah hi everyone
i'm amin dietz from capgemini
engineering
and
we've been working in a project together
with a startup called egg open
on
classifying and detecting kobit 19 on
ultrasound
lung ultrasound videos
and this poster is a very practical
approach to some of the ideas that we
already heard in the previous speeches
of
applying domain adaptation
so we had the problem actually started
um
training a model classifying it and we
had
acceptable results
and then at some point we received new
data from a different hospital
and every data scientist would say okay
great new data it's a dream
our performance must improve
but actually the performance stagnated
or was even worse
so
what was happening is when you looked at
the data
that uh there was a very strong bias
based from the hospitality west form and
it's very typical in medical data that
you have
bias everywhere like from different
patients different physiology physiology
and different
experimental setups different hardware
being used different hardware settings
and you try to mitigate that so you try
to pre-process your data to get rid of
that bias but sometimes it's not
possible sometimes you don't even know
what the bias is
and yeah so we use domain adaptation
to
to create a model that is independent
and
to bring all those distributions
together so this is what the post is
about and i can tell you more about that
in detail thank you
tamar is number nine
okay everybody i'm thomas from ce i work
in
action sheet sex inside you see
also in the fish there is fritz and
camille you want to talk to them too
so inside our action sheet
we want to answer the question
can active learning be better than
random selection of data points
for real world tasks
so active learning is people talked
about it already but it's a way to
address the problem of data being very
expensive to annotate
so it's the idea can we use the model to
pick out a subset of data
which is more important for to learn a
good
a good model a good representation
how that works in practice is normally
you start with a model you pick out some
some initial subset
you train your model on it you label
sorry you um
you you pump through the model the rest
of the unlabeled data and you pick out
the most uncertain data points in this
unlabeled base and then you label the
most uncertain ones and you go again
in cycles
so in our action sheet we're addressing
object detection problem
specifically traffic road scenes in the
bdd dataset with a yellow v5 model
so the idea is to kind of
to detect
boxes around objects like cars and
pedestrians etc
so if you want to hear about some first
results that we had inside the action
sheet you can come talk to us at the
poster
and we can also talk to you about the
the work that we're planning to do in
the next stages of our action sheets so
to do with
trying to understand how we can use
metadata
to improve the
process
and also looking at unsupervised machine
learning techniques as well like
semi-supervised learning
self-supervised learning as well so
that's
it hello everyone i'm your moliere i'm
working at serra as a phd student
and i will present you the slide has a
problem no matter
who's back okay okay thank you
i will present to you
the poster albert a cross domain
framework for
operational design domain specification
so the concept of operational
design domain come from the automotive
domain
and it's a tool to represent the
specification the limitation
on the capabilities of the syst of a
given system
so the idea here is to provide a tool to
generalize this concept to any domain
related to autonomous system
so we have several
three important aspects here the
ontology formalization
it's a structure language to represent
any concept concept from a domain
on the
[Music]
taxonomies it's a little bit your
content so the vocabulary that you will
use to represent
a concept
so
here we will uh
provide some cross-domain uh concept
like uh weather for example it can be
adapted uh
for several domains every system as
example working outside
and we provide a third
contribution it's
the operational design domain language
itself
so it's all the information relevant
to present
the
capabilities and limitations of the
system itself so it can be uh exposure
probabilities
on the like the dynamic aspects the
metrics that you can associate to some
operating conditions et cetera
[Applause]
okay
can you hear me
yes
so
i'm olivier math and i'm working at
capgemini engineering dems as ai program
manager and today i'm going to talk
about speech recognition under
constraint
so it's been a long time since
my like a scientific talk so it's very
challenging only two minutes but it's uh
yeah you lose time
so today vice
technology
omnipresent in our daily lives and we
can find it in our phones or computers
and also in our homes
however while speech recognition
technologies are
enough mature to be integrated into
marketable solutions they still have
some limitations for an adoption in the
industry
first
most of them are developed by large
group and gaffer who has access to
unlimited access to data and computing
resources
second
they
are mainly based on
cloud services which means that you will
have to send your data to the cloud
and
this can raise issues related to data
privacy and
gdpr
and this also means that if you don't
have access to internet you cannot
choose the service
and finally
they are not performing well on
industrial condition
mainly due to the noisy environment or
specific business vocabulary
or due to
data with a lower sampling rate
so in this context the question is how
can we develop speech recognition model
efficient model for industry
and in our work
we are taking the challenges of data
scarcity and
robustness of
speech recognition models
by developing new cutting-edge methods
based on state-of-the-art
approaches such as self-supervised
learning
and data centric ai approach in order to
build a
speech recognition solution on device
so please feel free to meet me during
the poster session if you want to know
more about how at calgary engineering we
are
developing a speech recognition solution
[Applause]
so hello everyone
my name is not uh levi but aj kozaki but
he's my co-worker in ca so i will be
presenting his work
so the topic of his work is around
randomized smoothing in
the special caves of early kid data set
as you all know um deep learning models
are susceptible to adversarial attacks
this means that a small perturbation
in the input is capable of fooling the
model
and deep learning models
and
randomized musing was initially
introduced in order to certify the
prediction of classifiers
by adding noise in the data set it is
possible to certify that the classifier
output will remain constant
within a certain radius around the
initial data and perturbed data
the problem is that in the regression
case of course if you change the inputs
you also change the output so this is a
slightly different situation
so during this work they were able to
use a method called percentile smoothing
and for which
it is possible to certify the prediction
of a regression model so certified that
regressor prediction will stay between
two bones the the blue ones that you see
in the picture
for again data which is slightly
perturbed
within a radius of the initial data
so please don't hesitate to come visit
us
during the poster session and thank you
very much
[Applause]
so we don't i think that dumitru is not
with us he wrote to me yes
yesterday evening that he was sick and
could not finally attend so we
hope that he will be better and the crl
is our last number 14
please
the next next one please
okay yes
so for this poster we took the subject
confidence.ai quite literally
as robots and intelligence agents are
expected to become more and more
prevalent in everyday contexts public
reception of robotics and ai is the
cornerstone of acceptance uptake and
research funding
of such technology
however the the complexity and the
opacity of the systems
can have a negative impact on the
trustworthiness of this system
so in explainable ai for example this
shortcoming this shortcoming sorry is
addressed by developing a solution that
aims at increasing user
efficiency the way that it is
used by the design of embodied virtual
agents
communicating about the system's results
and processes in a natural and human way
but this impression that the human ages
the virtual agent sorry creates can also
be a disturbing one and can have an also
a negative impact on the way we perceive
it
so how do we manage the impression that
this embodied agent can make
well we make first impressions very fast
50 milliseconds is sufficient to firm a
first form a first impression of a
person that we just meet and it is
spontaneous and it does not fall into a
vacuum
we use a lot of
non-verbal signals such as face voice
and body to judge people like we would
judge a book by its cover but we can use
it to design embodied virtual agents and
make sure that they are trusted that
they are perceived as competent and that
the persons feel safe and secure using
these
systems so this poster aims at opening a
distribution and presenting an approach
to the features of embodied ai that
elicit emotional response and influence
behavior in the human mission
interaction thank you thank you